>> Greg: DEMOCRATS SERIOUSLY
FREAKED OUT AFTER LEARNING
VOTERS ARE APPARENTLY FED UP
WITH THEIR WOKE POLICIES.
THE BLOW OUT IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO SCHOOL BOARD FREAK
OUT ELECTION IS NOT THE ONLY ONE
IN SIGN.
INTERNAL POLLING SAYS THAT THEY
ARE LOSING ON KEY PROTOCOLS FROM
DEFUNDING THE POLICE, TO
IMMIGRATION, TO THE BIG THEORY
THAT THE REPUBLICANS ARE WINNING
THE CULTURE WAR.
THERE IS DREAD, REAL DREAD
SPREADING AMONG MANY DEMOCRATS
THAT THE URBAN-BASED PARTY COULD
GO IN RURAL PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
SOME CANDIDATES ARE AFRAID TO
EVEN TELL VOTERS IN THOSE PARTS
WHICH PARTY THEY REPRESENT.
EVEN THE LIBERAL MEDIA IS
TELLING DEMOCRATS TO GET IT
TOGETHER.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE AFRAID THAT THE
PARTY IS GOING TOO FAR.
>> TOO MANY DEMOCRATS DON'T
SPEAK IN TERMS OF THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN COMPREHENDING WHAT THEY
ARE SAYING.
THE SPEAKER THAT GOT TO STEP
AWAY.
>> IF YOU GIVE THEM -- THEY'RE
FOCUSED ON THE WRONG THINGS THAT
DON'T MATTER.
YOU ARE GOING TO LOSE.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
>> Geraldo: WHAT ABOUT THAT
NOTION THAT THE DEMOCRATS COULD
GO EXTINCT IN AREAS LIKE WHERE
YOU LIVE?
>> Dana: STARTED TO HAPPEN.
IT'S NOT REPUBLICANS SAY NOT,
IT'S PEOPLE LIKE HEIDI HEITKAMP
WHO USED TO BE THE SENATOR FROM
NORTH DAKOTA.
SHE IS AT THIS ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
PLACES, YOU ARE SEEING THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THAT DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO BE COMPLETELY BOXED
OUT.
THEY DO REALLY WELL IN THE
CITIES, THEY FOCUSED HEAVILY ON
THE CITIES.
BUT IF YOU START TO SEE SOME OF
THE WORKING CLASS PULL AWAY FROM
DEMOCRATS, AND THAT INCLUDES
NONWHITE WORKING CLASS WHICH IS
STARTED UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP,
AND ALSO BECAUSE WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS POLITICAL
REALIGNMENT.
AND A GEOGRAPHICAL REALIGNMENT
WITH PEOPLE MOVING AND JOBS
MOVING.
IN THE UPPER MIDWEST AND GOING
TO THE SOUTH.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS GOING TO GO
EXTINCT, BUT THEY ARE AT A POINT
RIGHT NOW WHERE YOU'VE SEEN THAT
SLIP THAT GREG HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR A LONG TIME THAT ALL
OF THE SUDDEN THE REPUBLICANS
ARE PART OF THE WORKING CLASS
AND THERE'S A LITTLE BIT -- YOU
ARE SEEING IT EVERY DAY.
I POINT OUT THAT IF YOU JUST
LOOK AT THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
THAT GOT RECALLED, THAT WAS 80%
MARGIN IN SAN FRANCISCO.
SO IMAGINE IN A SWING COUNTY OR
A SWING STATE, THERE'S NOT THAT
MANY LEFT, BUT THAT MARGIN IS
GOING TO BE INCREDIBLE FOR
REPUBLICANS THIS YEAR.
>> YOU ARE A POLITICIAN, YOU
WEAR, DO YOU SENSE THAT THESE
MIDTERMS WILL BE THE ROUTE?
>> Jeanine: I WILL TELL YOU
WHY.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THESE
CULTURE WARS AND AMERICANS ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT
MATTER TO THEM FINANCIALLY.
GAS, FOOD PRICES, AND SAFETY.
SO EVERYTHING THAT THE LEFT IS
DOING FROM DEFUNDING THE POLICE
TO IMMIGRATION -- AND BY THE
WAY, JANUARY APPARENTLY WAS
ALMOST 200,000 PEOPLE COMING
THROUGH IN JANUARY.
ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
WHICH IS LIKE DOUBLE WHAT IT WAS
OF THE MONTH BEFORE.
SO AMERICANS ARE SAYING TO
THEMSELVES, WE ARE FEEDING,
HOUSING, AND EDUCATING ALL THESE
PEOPLE APPEARED WE CAN AFFORD TO
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE.
WE CAN'T AFFORD THE GAS PRICES.
AND THESE PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT WOKENESS.
VIRGINIA WAS A BELLWETHER, THIS
IS A BELLWETHER IN
SAN FRANCISCO, AND THEY WANT TO
SAY THIS IS ALL BECAUSE OF
DONALD TRUMP AND ALL BECAUSE OF
CLOSET REPUBLICANS?
THERE ISN'T A CLAUSE AT THE
REPUBLICAN IN OR ANYWHERE.
>> Geraldo: I'M A CLOSET
REPUBLICAN.
>> Greg: PREACHY JUDGMENTAL
GREG -- PEOPLE GET ANNOYED WITH
THAT.
WOKISM IS NOT THE OPPOSITE OF
ANY POLITICAL PARTY, IT'S THE
OPPOSITE OF FORGIVENESS.
THAT IS WHY EVERYONE IS SO
DISGUSTED BY IT.
IT'S 100% KIND OF A POLITICAL
ENTITY LIKE MARXISM OR MAOISM.
IT IS NOT A HUMAN FAVOR, I DO
SOMETHING THAT HUMANS HAVE BEEN
COERCED TO.
EXCEPT FOR ACADEMICS WHO ARE
LIVING SOME KIND OF ABSTRACT
UNIVERSE.
AND SOMEHOW THIS INFECTION
INTIMIDATED ITSELF INTO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BUT NOW IT IS
EATING THE PARTY FROM INSIDE.
THE SOLUTION I SEE IS THAT
DEMOCRATS NEED TO HAVE DEMOCRAT
LEADERS FIND FORMER WOKE TO
DEPROGRAM THE FORMER WOKE.
THE FORMER MEMBERS OF A CULT.
BUT WHAT YOU ARE SAYING FROM
MORNING JOE, THE A LARGE
STRATEGY, WHICH IS TO ACT LIKE A
REPUBLICAN.
SO SUDDENLY YOU ARE TOUGH ON
CRIME, YOU WANT TO CUT TAXES,
YOU RESTORED THE ORDER OF
PRIORITIES.
THAT IS BECAUSE YOU WANT TO WIN.
SO THAT RAISES THE QUESTION, IF
IT TAKES BEING REPUBLICAN TO
WIN, WHY DO YOU JUST BE A
REPUBLICAN?
IF THE POPULATION WANTS THIS
STUFF AND YOU AGREE THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT, WHY DO YOU PRETEND TO
BE A DEMOCRAT WHEN TIMES ARE
GOOD AND THEN BECOME A
REPUBLICAN WHEN TIMES ARE BAD?
>> Geraldo: IT WILL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE WHO STICKS
WITH IT.
REMEMBER WHEN BARACK OBAMA SAID,
BIN LADEN IS DEAD AND
GENERAL MOTORS IS ALIVE?
IT'S A NEW ONE.
BUILD BACK BETTER IS DEAD, COVID
IS ALIVE, INFLATION IS RISING.
>> Jesse: WHO CAME UP WITH
THAT ONE?
>> Geraldo: NOT ME.
THE QUESTION IS, CAN THE
DEMOCRATS SHAKE OFF THIS BURDEN?
>> Jesse: THEY CAN'T SHAKE
INFLATION AND THEY CAN FIGHT
CRIME OR THE OPEN BORDER, THAT'S
TOO MUCH TO SHAKE OFF.
THEY GOT COCKY BECAUSE THEY WON
A FEW CULTURE WARS.
THEY WON MY GAY MARRIAGE, THEY
WON MARIJUANA LEGALIZATION.
AND THEN THEY LOST THE FAX
MANDATE.
THE REASON WHY THEY ARE LOSING,
MANY REASONS WHY THEY ARE LOSING
THIS PARTICULAR WOKE CULTURE WAR
IS BECAUSE THEY WENT IN WITH A
DIVIDED ARMY.
MOST OF THE DEMOCRATS DON'T EVEN
WANT THIS CRAZY STUFF.
DO YOU THINK CHRIS ROCK,
DAVE CHAPPELLE, THE GUY ON HBO,
BELMAR -- THESE GUYS SNICKER
BEHIND THE SCENES.
THEY ARE ALWAYS TAKING PICTURES
WITH POLICE OFFICERS.
THEY ALL BY THAT COVERAGE.
THEY DON'T GET INTO ALL THAT
STUFF.
THEY JUST WANT SAFETY AND GOOD
SCHOOLS AND A REGULAR LIFE.
THE PROBLEM IS YOU HAVE THIS
SLIVER OF INSANITY AND THOUGHT
IS MOSTLY IN COLLEGE CAMPUSES
THAT PUSH THIS WICKED STUFF AND
THEY ARE SO LOUD AND OBNOXIOUS
THE REST OF THE PARTY IS LIKE
OKAY, OKAY, JUST RELAX.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SAY ANYTHING
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO GET
CANCELED THEMSELVES BE OF THE
REASON BESIDES TWITTER IS COVID.
THEY USED TO HAVE CLAM BAKES --
REMEMBER POLITICIANS USED TO GO
TO BARBECUES, THEY USE TO SHAKE
HANDS IN THE DISTRICT, THEY USED
TO MEET PEOPLE AND THEY USE TO
GET A VIBE ON WHAT THE COUNTRY
IS FEELING.
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT ANYMORE
APPEAR THE QUICKER THAT COVID IS
OVER, THE QUICKER DEMOCRATS CAN
GET BACK TO NORMAL.
>> Geraldo: THE MOST ACTIVE
MEMBERS STOLE THE MARCH ON THE
OLD SCHOOL DEMOCRATS.
THEY WERE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON AND AOC WAS SO
FAR TO HAVE THE MEN.
>> Dana: NANCY PELOSI
SHOULD'VE SQUASHED THAT